technology to improve your health is
among the highlights at this year's
Consumer Electronics Show the world's
largest consumer tech show opens this
morning in Las Vegas more than 170,000
people are expected to attend nearly
4,000 companies from innovative startups
to industry powerhouses like Google and
Samsung will showcase their products
Bryan Cooley from our partners at Cena
is at the show in Las Vegas Bryan good
morning good morning everybody so let's
talk about this auto presence here at
Nissan in particular showing off this
technology called b2v which means brain
to vehicle what is that it's like a
mind-reading concept yeah believe it or
not mind reading through this is kind of
my digital crown of thorns here this is
a piece you put on your head it's got
these little sensor probes underneath it
and when you Don this it will connect to
a future Nissan vehicle to wirelessly
communicate what I'm thinking to the
vehicle so maybe it could react a
quarter to a half a second faster than
it would by me actually grabbing the
controls or stabbing at the brakes now
this might have seemed like crazy stuff
a couple years ago but the way we're
going now with connected technologies in
cars this isn't that nutty and it could
be used for safety it could be used for
things like getting a more sporty feel
out of a car when you're in that mood
and Nissan is deadly serious about
testing with this it's pretty cool right
and this is sort of become one of the
new places to announce the big auto news
right yes it absolutely has and it's
interesting because the giant Detroit
Auto Show is coming immediately after
this one wraps up next week and yet
you're seeing a bifurcation go on here
if you're doing connected technologies
in cars that make them come alive as
part of your digital life that's
probably being announced here if you're
showing off a new model or an amazing
new powertrain electrification
hybridization that's probably still
gonna happen at the traditional auto
shows but there's an awful lot of
blurring and I'll be honest with you
it's kind of a blood battle between the
two franchises now we've been hearing
about this digital assistance in the
bathrooms and Gail and I have been
wondering what do you need that for I
didn't know there were a lot of options
in the bathroom Brian
oh it's so much easier just a lot of
plumbing yeah well it turns out Kohler
and Moen these two companies we all know
well that are big makers of kind of
fancy high-end appliances and such for
the bathroom one of them rolled out a
smart mirror with Amazon Alexa built in
so you can verbally control the lighting
or what audio is playing and through the
mirror as well and then Mullen has
Amazon Alexa controlled shower controls
you know you get in the shower and you
know what temperature you like but you
don't know how to set it you turn the
knob about here right we all know that
routine right here you would just use
Alexa and say hey Alexa get my shower
ready at 103 degrees and get it
pre-warmed but don't waste water spewing
out all that hot water out until I tell
you that I'm getting in it's actually a
very smart concept an existing issue
that we all feel alright that makes
sense I'm looking at that little guy
beside you buddy he's creeping me out a
little bit how does he work what's it
what's his deal Brian buddy buddy is one
of our favorite robots right now in a
crop of robots that have bubbled up in
about the last couple of years kind of
like a hyperactive kid in some ways
buddy is a smart voice reacting robot
that can become a companion around the
house it has all kinds of sensors and
cameras and you talk back and forth to
it hello buddy I'm listening buddies
always trust me hello buddy can you
dance
I think buddy's about to dance get ready
for this so here we go whoa okay so
buddy is like a little Home Companion
but also can run around the house I'm
gonna grab buddy if things go wrong here
and can keep an eye on things for you it
can see if the pets are doing okay if
your kids are home it could be your
remote control eyes if you want to see
how things are going but he can roam
around for you from wherever you are in
the world Ryan you can check out your
house that way Brian Brian let us know
when buddy can fold the laundry okay but
in the mean time I understand that
L'Oreal has a chip that you can wear on
your fingernail what does it do that's
right if you're in the fingernail art
this is the ultimate fingernail art
because this is a little chip you put on
your fingernail and what it is is a UV
sensor and it's going to keep track of
your ultraviolet exposure and it has no
batteries and it's super tiny tube
nine millimeters and it looks cool and
the idea is it will report into a
smartphone app and let you know what
your cumulative UV exposure is for the
next year they'll offer it through
dermatologists and then in 2019 you'll
be able to buy it for about forty bucks
and just use this thing you the exposure
is such an important thing to keep an
eye on what amazed how amazing is
something it's a lot idea about this
yeah that's good to monitor yeah yeah
hey it really nice to see you Brian
thank you so much thanks guys we got a
lot going on here clearly clearly the
robots still dancing